[Music]
the scp foundation depends on staying
out of the public eye and away from
public perception in order to accomplish
their vital work if the public were to
find out about the foundation and the
nightmares it spends every day
protecting us from it would be total
chaos worldwide they would be so busy
trying to feel detention from civilians
politicians and reporters fending off
every random joe with a smartphone who
wanted to take an instagram story of
scp-096 and endanger his life that they
wouldn't have time to contain all the
world-ending anomalies out there so they
operate entirely under the radar but it
wasn't always this way there was a time
when the world at large knew about the
scp foundation and the researchers had
to find out a way to step out of the
spotlight for good like everything else
about the scp foundation it wasn't easy
the road to the foundation's current
cloak of secrecy was paved with trial
and error
experimental magic and a formidable
woman known by the alias elizabeth
crocker this is the story of scp-001
the frontis piece also known as the
pikmin blank proposal it all started in
1964 when several national governments
discovered that the foundation's
overwatch command was working both for
and against all of the countries
involved in the cold war canada the ussr
israel and lebanon and egypt all
withdrew support for the foundation the
most catastrophic was the withdrawal of
support from the united states
government ordered by lyndon b johnson
after his national security team
discovered the foundation had been
involved in the cuban missile crisis at
the same time as the foundation's
relationship with these global powers
was crumbling the foundation made one of
its most powerful enemies ever person of
interest 001 also known by her alias
elizabeth crocker was a member of the
cia beginning in 1959.
there she fell in love with a fellow
agent named dr alexandre hilbert who is
working on a quantum brace capable of
altering probability in 1964 the
foundation reached out to dr hilbert in
an attempt to recruit him but he refused
shortly after this he was killed during
a test of the quantum brace crocker
attributed his death to the foundation
believing them to have tampered with his
machine in order to punish him for
turning down their offer after the death
of her love crocker swore to destroy the
scp foundation for good on october 19
1967 crocker disguised herself as the
personal driver of a member of the o5
council and shot her one dozen times
before dropping her body outside of a
foundation safe house in san francisco a
note was found on the body with a
message from elizabeth crocker it ended
with this promise it's high time
somebody broke up your tidy little
racket no
more than one somebody everybody we're
going to contain you and you're going to
suffocate agent crocker endangered the
foundation's security seeming to possess
a knowledge of all of its outposts as
well as the ability to decipher even its
most secure communication ciphers
several members of personnel hold up in
havana cuba during january of 1968 began
to brainstorm looking for a way to
increase security and keep the
foundation together in the face of these
new threats a number of different
researchers were in attendance including
dr eric euler a thamatologist or a
scientist in the field of ritual magic
though some of his colleagues failed to
treat him with the respect he deserved
some out of skepticism and some out of
outright bigotry towards his jewish
identity euler was a brilliant mind with
an idea that could save them all dr
euler proposed a potent solution to the
chaos spreading across the world as
companies owned by the foundation were
being exposed and destroyed and their
facilities reduced to rubble dr euler
suggested that it might be possible to
place some sort of illusion over the
businesses acting as fronts for the
foundation preventing them from being
found out by any outsiders catty
o'donnell responded that that wouldn't
be enough that they needed to find a way
to get the world to forget the
foundation existed at all at least for a
little while dr euler at a loss reached
out to site 43 to see if they had any
thamatologists at their facility there
was one in fact dr okori dr edwin
falkirk and chief of security and
containment martin strauss were sent in
to brief him on the situation at hand
during their conversation okorie
reported thamaturgic changes made around
his place of work the information he
shared caught strauss's attention
immediately after a moment of thought
strauss knew exactly what it meant and
who was behind it it was a sign from
someone who would prove immensely
helpful and a mysterious man named thelo
zwist thelo's wist also known as person
of interest 382 as well as a long list
of aliases is a highly skilled
cryptomancer who has used his control of
anomalies to render himself functionally
immortal he performs a form of magic
using language and was previously
associated with an organization known as
the gif schreiber or the poison riders
since his discovery zwist has spent
decades involved in a cat and mouse game
of sorts with site 43 director dr v l
scout now the same doctor scout had
planted a reference to zwist in the mind
of dr okorie to suggest that the
foundation contact the elusive man for
help with this new plan in motion dr
okorre attempted to make contact with
zwist in march of 1968. he met the man
at an abandoned building in the harbour
front district of toronto there he found
zwiest who claimed to be expecting him
he teased okore about the unwanted
attention the foundation was receiving
as well as the danger posed by elizabeth
crocker eventually he asked are you here
to ask for my help or did i let you find
me for no good reason okorie admitted
that he was seeking help and zwiss
explained his special method of
combining writing with ritual magic in
order to imbue the words with power or
danger he offered to craft a phrase a
series of words that when written on a
sign created by him would keep the
public from seeing who the foundation
truly was he offered to do it exactly
once but not recreate it going forward
all he needed was a piece of language to
craft his spell dr okore offered an
initialism as a possibility
suggesting the scp that comes before the
foundation zwizz laughed delightfully at
this and said simply
this is going to work out splendidly one
week later zwist brought dr okore a
simple logo design for a non-existent
business called scout's cargo packing as
well as a chemical formula for an
antidote that would inoculate anyone who
received it against the sign's magical
properties after approval by the o5
council the logo was printed on a fleet
of moving trucks that could then be used
to transport personnel and items across
north america without any detection it
was highly effective and the foundation
began plans to spread this new
protective measure throughout all of its
facilities in may of 1968 a collision
along route 66 in the united states
damaged one of the trucks removing its
magical functionality curious about the
repercussions of zwist's work being
destroyed and about any potentially
dangerous effects dr euler formed the
mimesis and cryptomancy research group
where he worked alongside dr orkore and
dr ilse renders as dr render suffered
from a condition that rendered her
unable to leave a sealed chamber in
site-43 euler was reassigned to that
facility and worked alongside her and
okore there during their research the
team learned that damage to zwist's
riding changed its properties in a
variety of ways and he continued
breaking down the trucks to try and
understand them meanwhile elizabeth
crocker had not let up in her dogged
pursuit of the foundation's destruction
a shipping container bearing the
insignia of a defunct foundation front
company was discovered in the port of
los angeles on july 2nd 1968 containing
the badly beaten but still alive abrasha
skokolski a note was pinned to his tie
reading can you feel the noose yet back
at site 43 euler renders and okore
reached a breakthrough the power of
zwist's work came not from the full
words of scout's cargo packing but from
the initials scp itself using a
combination of grammar and magic much to
the excitement of every english teacher
and fantasy fan they could transfer the
properties of zwist's sign to any other
sign bearing the same initials just like
it always has at the foundation it all
came down to s
c
p a variety of former front businesses
were revived all bearing the same
initials there was star city poker
supply control and purification and of
course sawyer's cheesy pretzels the high
from this breakthrough quickly gave way
to another devastating loss however as
agent crocker struck again in
johannesburg south africa agent crocker
infiltrated an scp site under the alias
dr gabrielle fish there she exacerbated
existing racial tensions and took
advantage of the apartheid state to sow
discord crocker killed regional director
jansen and dumped his body near site 19
with a node in this jacket pocket it
said you're running out of continents as
the research team kicked off their
efforts into high gear preparing an
official research proposal on quantum
lingua physics elizabeth crocker
continued her grim work in the people's
republic of china she used cryptomancy
to trigger severe paranoia in chairman
mao zedong drawing his attention to
foundation representatives hiding in the
people's republic of china this forced
dr noble to escape the country leaving
behind any foundation influence in china
there was yet again a note left for her
five minutes to midnight crocker was
closing in next crocker aligned herself
with u.s president richard nixon tipping
him off to the existence of the
foundation and convincing him to have
the us army occupy at the facility euler
okore and renders had to act and act
fast each of the doctors tentatively
signed off on the project ready to put
the experiment into practice meanwhile
crocker got bolder and more violent she
killed foundation personnel whenever she
got the chance abandoning long-form
political strategy in favor of spectacle
she used an auditory cryptomantic agent
embedded in a recording of i wanna hold
your hand by the beatles to kill ten
foundation personnel in a safe house in
scotland next she infiltrated site 43
where she was defeated by intervention
from zwist himself at site zero one on
july 9 1969
dr euler and dr okoray now put their
creation into place called the
frontispiece within two weeks its
effects had spread across the world
cloaking every foundation front and its
anomalous effects by june of 1970 the
foundation could come out of frightened
panicked hiding and resume regular
hiding they were working actively in the
world again building new sites all the
time in august of 1971 one of the
foundation's trucks was unable to cross
beyond the berlin wall as the guards
stationed there only read the cyrillic
alphabet dr euler proposed a solution in
the form of a new york-based artist
whose work posed similar properties to
zwist's writing this artist was a man
named andy warhol and the foundation
commissioned him to create an
imagery-based version of the
frontispiece compatible with all known
languages allowing the effects to extend
to regions that use different alphabets
in the later 1970s crocker resurfaced
and escaped custody and shortly after dr
okore was found murdered in his home she
remained active through the 80s aligning
herself with the reagan administration
in an ineffective attempt to make him
launch an attack on the foundation
currently it is believed that she is
dead as she would now be over 100 years
old however if zwist is any indication
there are tools out there that might
have allowed her to extend her life far
beyond what is natural to this day the
work of the original research team lives
on even as the scientists behind it have
passed away it is highly effective with
one exception repeated exposure to
anomalous activity renders someone
immune to the effects of the
frontispiece otherwise however the
foundation remains secured contained and
protected a final letter from thelo's
wist was recovered among dr euler's
effects after his death in 2013
reminding them of their duty to protect
the world and do the right thing he
ended the letter with this your course
was said the moment i beg said lovely
little flaw into the writing which you
stole i robbed you of the opportunity to
become the tyrants of all our nightmares
you will have no choice but to be better
than that because evil only flourishes
in ease you will never know ease you and
those who come after you you need to
keep doing the work you forget to decide
how well you do it of course and on that
matter i have a suggestion do it right
stop compromising principles now go
check out
scp-001 when day breaks and scp-001 the
scarlet king for more insights into the
fascinating world of scp-001